cocaine found at the White House the
Secret Service says it's got no idea who
left a small baggie the stuff inside the
White House and that the investigation
is now closed to the surprise and
disbelief of many the bag was found as
you may recall inside a guest entryway
In The West Wing or to the West Wing
rather two weekends ago about 10 days or
so in a cubby where visitors leave their
cell phones the FBI says it looked for
traces of DNA and fingerprints but found
no reliable results no physical evidence
and the Secret Service said that these
surveillance cameras apparently did not
provide any additional leads Republican
house Speaker Kevin McCarthy is now
questioning how the White House which of
course has a round-the-clock security
could not identify who left the cocaine